Jasin
Hey um I was just gonna head out some
things to do today
oh you want to get like breakfast or
something no I don't think so I'm not
hungry
I'm just ago okay let me get dressed
I'll show you don't worry about it I'm
I'll let myself out and it's easier same
way I came in right just it's easier so
is this about last night no uh yes I
don't know I just I don't want to talk
about last night this was a one-time
thing I mean it felt pretty real to me
we we had a lot to drink okay and
mistakes happen when you drink that much
mistake this was a mistake to you that's
not what I'm saying
I'm just I'm not ready for this you know
and I didn't sign up for something so
serious but last night you said I'm
embarrassed about last night haha whoa
uh-oh my side all mostly like this
you're not sleeping on the bed I only
don't move much you don't like garden
would rent a room you're my brother to
me we're brothers I love you like my
brother it's not weird
it's like we would love each other's
cool I love each other honestly we just
say this like everyday to each other
idea I want to go there you know I want
to wake up in the morning and every day
just text you I love you hope you wanted
it we should do it I mean I'm a little
embarrassed to go but this is weird like
what happened last night you know I
don't do that
like talk about those things like
feelings or whatever I don't know man I
just like felt like lonely for a long
time
and like didn't really have anyone like
real in my life you know and I just like
I don't know if I could have gotten
through this without you you know oh oh
thank you yeah like you know we can't go
back to how things were right those days
are over
like everything's changed now yeah I
know I don't want to go back I've never
had a friend like that oh I can just
talk to I really liked last night and I
don't regret it I don't regret anything
I said that's not why you'd be here
friends people you
you like a brother okay so what now what
what how do we do this only go get
breakfast yeah Mickey D's or Denny's
you know Mickey D's guy we're going to
Denny's you have calves Clippers tonight
who you got man you know kairi's my dude
like Harry's hurt Wow